hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen hier heute meine damen und
herren zur find the difference ich hatte
leider keine buchstaben r eine differenz
challenge bei der feinde difference
challenge geht es darum dass wir uns ein
video anschauen und in diesem video
werden zwei fotos eingeblendet ihr kennt
das wahrscheinlich aus irgendwelchen
kindermagazin das foto auf der linken
seite ist dann ein komplett richtig
korrektes foto und das foto auf der
rechten seite ist dann allerdings ein
foto in dem einige fehler versteckt sind
von daher schon uns heute das video an
only just can't find the difference one
hundred and feel
ja also ich bin alles andere als ein
geniales allerdings würde ich sagen
fangen wir mal direkt an hier schon eine
supertolle animation find the difference
moana also es ist dieses moana ist ihm
auf deutsch ist der film glaube ich war
ja irgendwie ein animationsfilm um
diesen film geht es ja heute auf jeden
fall hier steht josef thirty seconds vor
termin bekommen spieler howman you were
able to get also wir haben 30 sekunden
zeit für jedes foto normalerweise mache
ich es bei solchen rätsel quiz videos
immer so dass ich auf pause drücken und
ihr selbst überlegen aber hier heute
stelle ich mich wirklich und ich stelle
euch auch der herausforderung innerhalb
von 30 sekunden herauszufinden was die
feder sind also drückt nicht auf pause
und versucht alle fehler zu finden das
erste foto meine damen und herren wird
jetzt jeden moment eingeblendet und da
haben wir schon als wir haben 30
sekunden zeit
die sache ist ich weiß auch gar nicht es
ist ja eigentlich egal welches korrekt
aber nicht korrekt ist auf der einen
seite ist auf jeden fall ein fehler bei
der anderen beim anderen ist kein fehler
dann bin ich bescheuert
ja es ist das ist 11 gleiche foto auch
die perle dafür die pferde dafür
gefährdet
2000 jahre später gpa-djp alter schwede
habe ich habe wirklich auf den letzten
drücker ich glaube ich hatte noch drei
sekunden zeit oder so habe ich das noch
gefunden
ich habe mich halt auf die kleinen
sachen hier fokussiert ihnen wie hier
hinten oder hier an den haaren oder
sondern was die perle
okay okay dann wäre das level 1 wenn es
ein levelsystem ist nicht gleich
ziemlich am arsch hindert hat das zweite
foto meine lieben freunde ist dieses
hier ein wir haben wieder 30 sekunden
zeit also ich glaube es ist irgendwas
mit den blüten weil da ja so unfassbar
viele sind aber ich will mich da jetzt
auch nicht nur darauf konzentrieren
etwas essen passiert als er ist das ein
schwein
hier komme hier hat das schweinchen
fleck und da hat es keinen fleck also es
ist definitiv das ort von dem
schweinchen
ich dachte wirklich erst das ist was mit
den blumen im hintergrund zu tun hat
weil da halt so viele gelbe
verschiedenen blumen waren aber ich
glaube dass wir auch wieder zu schwer
gewesen und ja ich applaudiere gerade
für mich selbst allerdings machen wir
nun auch schon direkt weiter mit dem
dritten bild hier meine damen und herren
das ist dieses hier
ich schaue natürlich auch als erstes
direkt wieder auf die kette aber da sind
alle sachen drin das hatten wir auch
schon im ersten level ein viertel der
zeit ist um wir haben wenn es sind jahre
hier und jetzt hier ja ich glaub ja das
sind
aber das ist ein stück haare
abgeschnitten worden da die einst choral
jedes foto liebe zuschauer ich bin
diesmal wirklich gespannt ob das von
level system ist weil bisher fand ich
das erste sogar mit am schwierigsten
hier bei der kette ist glaube ich alles
korrekt auf beiden seite 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 auf der rechten seite und auf der 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
es ist die kette bin ich einfach geil
oder ist die webseite ein
richtig bin nicht schlau da ist s video
dobhan das fünfte foto meine lieben
zuschauer
ich bin wirklich gespannt ob das hier
noch irgendwie schwieriger wird bei den
blumen im haar kranz ist alles richtig
soweit ich das sehe
und da ist keine insel
ja will einfach mal der insel weg
gemacht obwohl es ehrlich gesagt er so
aussieht wird eine insel hin gemacht
worden seien also die antwort sehen wir
auch hier wieder eingeblendet ist dann
tatsächlich die insel sechstes foto was
wir hier eingeredet bekommen kommt nun
und zwar haben wir ja die sind die möwen
sorry aber hier sind drei löwen 23
und hier sind nur zwei löwen
ich dachte echt dass da vielleicht auch
pro seite dann so 345 sachen falsch sind
aber hier ist ja wirklich immer bei
jedem foto nur ein gegenstand verändert
worden also wir sehen jetzt auch dass
die mögen natürlich wieder das falsche
sind als ich hätte mir da wirklich
gedacht dass es schwieriger ist
allerdings kommt nun das siebte foto mh
ich glaube allerdings mittlerweile nicht
mal mehr dass das vor ihm habe ich zu
gute augen
hier ist die muschel
panik
man werde dieses café quiz gemacht herr
riedel cent puzzles zugehört gesperrt
von youtube alter sorry aber wie kann
man denn so ein video nitro genie ist
kein feind bedürfnis werde dann auch
noch 100 prozent also das sorry ich habe
zwar gute augen
aber ich wahnsinn achtes foto haben wir
jetzt hier
es gibt zumindest nichts was auf den
ersten blick ins auge sticht wo man sich
denkt okay das könnte falsch sein wie
die möwen oder irgendwas anderes alter
wheelock ich habe direkt dass man harre
gecheckt kette aber alter ich finde
nichts ein paar sekunden später einmal
bin ich dumm ich finde tatsächlich
nichts nein ich hab ich habe ich habe
nichts ich hab nichts kein scheiß ich
habe nichts gefunden
ja das ist das wo ich bei den ersten
wirklich nicht darauf geachtet habe das
sind genau diese fehler wo ich bei den
ersten 12 bildern drauf geachtet hatte
weil ich dachte dass sie da einen fehler
ein worden aber das haben sie nicht weil
sie dabei den offensichtlich in sachen
was eingebaut damit jetzt hier ist auf
einer dieses pack segel falsch also beim
achten bild habe ich auf jeden fall hart
verkackt gerade ich habe bisher so von
acht gezeigten sachen nur sieben richtig
dass jetzt jetzt das neunte ich lasse es
mal wieder durchlaufen
wir haben schwein auf beiden seiten
jedoch ihr komisches nudelholz hatte
oder was auch immer das ist hat sie auf
beiden seiten die die kette ist auch
komplett richtig angezogene sachen auf
finger hatte auch noch alle freunde ich
möchte
gar nicht aussprechen aber ich finde
kann ich habe keine fehler gefunden ich
habe keinen gefunden
[Musik]
nein nein
walter diese kann dieses hier meinen die
dieses ding dieses lange ist nicht hier
auf der seite
robert was wird dieser krieg ersteller
von diesem café la kings soll sich
verkehrt noch mal in sein verpacktes
knie karten ja ok bleibt ruhig also das
war auf jeden fall gerade das neunte und
somit vorletzte foto aus dieser reihe
nun kommt allerdings das letzte foto ist
es eine alte dame am strand wir
vergleichen erst mal wieder der stock da
ist nichts anders im ohr hat sie auch
auf beiden seiten was die kette ist es
ist wahrscheinlich wieder irgendwie
sonne strand dienst oder so eheleute
also ich meine ihr könnt ja mal mit
raten ich mache hat extra nicht meine
facetime größer aber ich muss ich muss
gar nicht hier
dieses ding ist nicht auf dieser seite
her habe ich zumindest noch das letzte
richtig und zwar hier saison
eingeblendet krank desto mehr ich gesagt
habe hey wie easy ist dieses video desto
schwieriger wurde ist so homann evaluate
the ghetto wird hier noch eingeblendet
also ich habe von zehn gezeigten
vergleichsbildern habe ich glaube ich
jetzt acht richtig beantworten können
und die fehler finden können im hier ist
das scoreboard die view the very keen
einmal europe jetzt okay das haben wir
nicht also wir haben ja nicht 10 471
redigierte observations ja wie viel grad
fotos fix you can do little bett höher
also wenn ihr nur die hälfte
bewusst haben wir gefunden haben von den
fehlern dann seid ihr quasi schon halb
blind und if you got one two three you
have got to try harder
also wer wirklich bei diesem video
weniger als fünf richtig hatte bei dem
komme ich persönlich zu hause vorbei und
howie meine brille ins gesicht an der
stelle würde ich somit das heutige video
als auch beenden meine lieben freunde
wenn es euch gefallen hat das gerne
einen daumen hoch bei diesem video ihr
da schreibt wir gern mal bitte und in
die kommentare ob ich so etwas noch mal
machen soll
also es gibt unfassbar viele feinde
difference challenges und amerika geht
das gerade voll ab und das hier ist
jetzt dachte ich eine relativ schwere
aber anscheinend war sie doch nicht so
schwer also wenn ich da noch mal ein
video zu machen soll in ein zwei wochen
und vielleicht dann ein video nehmen
soll wo oft nicht nur bei einem bild nur
einen fehler versteckte sondern mehrere
dann ist das ganze noch mal ein bisschen
komplex sondern schreibt mir gerne und
in die kommentare nutzt bei fortnight
gern diesen code luca als supportact
würde mich sehr freuen dann könnt ihr
euch kostenlos unterstützen und jetzt
kommt das aus
[Musik]